This one is just an arm drag. You grip
with your crossalle arm. So, it's his
right arm and my right arm right here
behind the elbow tricep area. And I'm
just going to pull him past here. Pull
still. When you pull, we're not going
past him yet.
Keep still shift your weight him. So,
you can use a lot of force if you want.
the same mechanics, but I'm not just
pulling past me, but down this way. My
weight has to drop.
[Music]
I'm going to combine that and then I'm
going to follow him into this.
I'm going to hold his bicep and hold his
wrist and pull it across my chest
from here. Boom. Follow it to here.
I'm going to do progression.
So, he's going to go and I'm going to
catch this arm and do the same thing.
He goes. I'm looking. Catch it and go.
You go
again. Faster.
Faster.
>> Okay. Progressions on the arm drive.
>> Got it.
>> Yes, sir. Now he's doing the same. This
drill is on me for me. Okay. So when we
start over, it's I know what he's going
to do. Okay. I just don't know where
he's going to end up. So I have to be
ready. I'm not saying I'm not saying
that I want you to balance, but I'm
ready. This is my mind. Okay. He goes
and I'm right there.
So, I'm not bouncing, but my mind is
ready to go. He go, let's start it again
from from the top.
We walk in. He goes
already there. Okay, we're not going to
start at that starting point anymore.
So, we're out here, right?
>> We walk in. He's primary. I know he's
going to try for it first. Okay. Uh, I'm
the cover officer. So, he goes, when he
walks in, I know what I'm doing. I where
he goes and he goes and
the only difference is we're not
starting all static like that. Okay, I
go on him. He goes,
>> "Okay, go."
>> Tristan, you be the
Let's say as we're walking towards him,
he starts to take a fighting stance, but
then we're not closing. Now we have
assaulted. Okay, we out comes the taser,
out comes the taunt. Got it. So, it's
the guy who's passive. But if I run
towards him and now he draws a weapon,
now we're out of luck. I can't get my
force option anymore. So, it's as I can
only move as fast as I can process
information. And you probably can't do
it at a jog. Okay. So, we're just
walking in. You're the dude, sir. Go
back.
>> That means you're the man, right? Do the
freaking command.
>> So, you walk in there authoritatively.
Good. Boom.
>> Okay. Got it, sir.
>> But I'm not jogging in. Okay. Try it
again. Okay.
Meaning, I'm not walking in like this.
You see that?
>> As I'm getting closer, my hands are
starting to come up. You see?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay.
And that's not only going to get the arm
right faster, but if he throws the
strike, I'm right there for the strike.
Okay.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay.
>> So, no more walking in with your hands
like that. As you get into striking
range, your hands are already for in
place for the arm drag and ready to
defend yourself. Okay?
>> It's not always going to be like this
where the guy stays still. If you stay
still, we'll do that. Okay? But a lot of
times you're coming in and he's just
like moving like that. So now if he was
primary and I start moving towards that,
who's got it? Yes, sir.
>> He's got it. So he'll take it. Do you
understand?
>> Yes, sir.
>> If I'm moving straight back, you'll just
close faster faster and you're in it and
you got it. Okay. Understand?
>> Yes, sir.
>> But if he starts circling or moving left
or right, it's going to go to one or the
other. And they got to be dynamic. Okay.
So, they're coming in, right? And here
you can communicate like you heard uh
Tristan say, I got it. Okay. Understand?
Yes, sir.
>> She's not going to know what that means.
Okay. All right. Let's try it. Use force
law. You know the answer, say the
answer. You don't have to save it for
the
Okay. What's his level of resistance
after I told him, "You're under arrest.
I want you to turn around or I want you
to sit down." And he didn't do it. He's
not in an assaultive stance. He's not
trying to run away.
>> Passive resistance. Okay. What's the
proportional force to passive
resistance?
>> Non.
>> Non-deadly. That's why we're grappling
with him. Do you understand?
>> If he took an assaultive stance, then
we're now at intermediate force. That's
where the taser, the baton, the pepper
spray, all that stuff comes out. Okay.
The civilian is going to try to grapple
with that guy. We're not the civilian.
We're going to bring force options in
because is he searched yet?
>> No.
>> I don't know if he has a weapon or not.
Okay. So, that's why we don't go grapple
people because I'm not grappling when
there's a that he has a weapon. He can
draw it in that tie up. Okay.
So,
in this case, he's passive and we're
usually non deadly. We'll do it slow
now. He's dancing around.
Okay.
And we're here.
We can now kind of gather ourselves,
right? You feel some control over him.
You can talk to each other now, right?
You want to give him a command because
we have feasibility. Hey, we want you to
lay on your stomach. And as we're doing
that, we are going to take his balance
forward while holding him up because he
can't use his hands to stop his face
from hitting the street. Do you
understand that? Yes, sir. You got that?
>> Hey, we want you to lay on your stomach.
Lay on your stomach. Lay on your
stomach. Lay on your stomach. And now
he's down. Okay, we'll do it again.
We'll just start from here.
I don't want to go down on a knee if I
don't have to. And one, but if you have
to, you have to. Better to keep the
control.
Ideally though, what I'll do is I'll
take this bicep tie and let my arm
extend and start to control the elbow.
Okay. So, you can just watch
there. I'm here. I go once you lay on
his stomach. lay on his stomach and I go
to this elbow control. This doesn't
change. Okay. Again,
we're together.
Hey, lay on your stomach. Lay on her
stomach. Push the elbow up. Okay. And
we're here like that. We're driving that
shoulder into the ground. Try to get
upstairs.
>> Got it. Yes, sir.
>> Do it again now from the start.
We already gave all the commands. He's
not doing it. Slide to go in.
Cut it. Hey, lay on the ground. Lay on
the ground. Lay on the ground. Lay on
the ground. Okay. And we're here. All
right. Do it at that kind of slow pace
like that. Less dynamic than the last
drill cuz we're learning a new skill. Do
not let him boom slam on the street.
Okay. What I mean by that,
we're actually holding him up. Try to
slap your face on the street,
try to slam it on the street.
You see?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. We have to be in position to
address their weight being affected by
gravity. All right. Try. I said you
could
recol, you know, recollect yourselves
and that might take a while, but if
everyone's good and it feels good, no
one's off balance, do you got it?
>> Yes, sir.
>> You already recollected, just go. Yes,
sir.
>> Okay. Just give the command. So, we're
here. We're back a little more dynamic.
He's going in. Our hands are going up.
Boom. Get on the ground. Get on the
ground. Get on the ground.
Okay. There's no big pause.
Lay on your stomach. We I already felt
we were in position. Everyone had their
balance and the command came right away.
And same with the execution. Okay. All
right. Change squad.